Harmony Dillon is the chairwoman of the
Republican National Lawyers Association
and of course a famous lawyer herself
she joins us today hermit thanks so much
for coming on so I notice I'm not a
lawyer but I noticed they didn't charge
him with a crime if it if it was a crime
why isn't he being charged with a crime
I'm confused as to what this is
well look as you mentioned Leticia James
came into office bragging about how she
was going to get Trump she seems to be
obsessed with him and you know denies
the legitimacy of his election and then
it took her three years to get to this
point and some would say that because
she's trailing in the polls in her race
for attorney general this is time to
help boost her ratings and that's really
what this is about so you're correct
Tucker she could not find any crime that
she could indict president Trump for she
has referred this matter to the southern
district of New York in case they can
find something but let's look at what
she did file on uh in in New York state
fraud has a six-year statute of
limitations so they're really basically
focusing on things that happen before
Donald Trump became president and his
family members got involved in the
government like Ivanka Trump so they're
really looking at very stale old stuff
that nobody bothered about until this
time and what we're really talking about
is the differences of opinion about
valuation of assets that were heavily
negotiated with banks and so Leticia
James's complaint 220 Pages worth belies
a shocking naivete about the realities
of business about the realities of how
properties are financed about how
businesses operate and it's really like
you said very small potato stuff and if
it were done by anybody else it wouldn't
be the subject of a complaint like this
and so this is entirely political Tucker
and it is not how a Attorney General of
the United States should be using their
awesome political power
so if there was a victim of this fraud
it would be the banks but my
understanding is the banks didn't
complain about this did I get that right
there are no victims there this is a
victimless complaint nobody is
complaining and the banks all got their
money back everybody is Happy except for
Leticia James
or meet Dylan thanks so much for coming
on tonight
appreciate it my pleasure subscribe to
the Fox News YouTube channel to catch
our nightly opens stories that are
changing the world and changing your
life from Tucker Carlson tonight